hi adam hi
thank you so much for doing this i'm
such a huge fan of your work and
obviously of this film one of the best
movies of all time i i wanted to ask you
you know again not only one of the best
movies of all time you have one of the
best character introductions of all time
marion's first scene you know from the
way you say indiana jones
to you know the punch and all this
business with the shot glasses
i'm wondering what you remember from you
know putting that scene together was
that all on the page was that stuff that
you guys all worked out once you got in
there
some of it was on the page and some of
it we worked out when we got in there i
mean the scene
on the page was a great scene and um
you know little bits and pieces got
added along the way
um you know a lot of the things you know
um
uh that had to do with you know uh
kind of the intricacies of how they
moved through the room and her
kind of throwing the shot glasses and a
lot of those got added because you know
they they
you kind of have to be in the room and
and and
a lot of things that had to do with the
medallion and all got kind of worked out
in this
in the space um but but
uh it was a wonderful scene it was the
scene that i had auditioned with so it
was
it was my entry into getting to know the
character in the film was that that
scene
well you know i also wanted to ask
there's this there's this legend behind
the scene between you and paul freeman
uh where you're hiding the knife that
that was improvised zoring is that true
it was improvised and so i was i didn't
like the scene because the scene on the
page
was marion
trying to seduce uh the bellock
character
and as it was written it seemed like she
was sincerely gonna seduce him and
possibly sleep with him in order to you
know
get get something from him uh whether it
was to escape or whether what
and i just thought um this is not
this is not good for the character or
for the story i thought this is somebody
who truly loves indiana jones
so paul and i talked about it and he
agreed that we could do something more
interesting
and so we went to stephen and stephen
said okay look
if you think you can do something more
interesting you guys go off and work on
it and you show it to me
and if i think it's more interesting
we'll shoot it that way
so we we went at lunch time every day we
would go
because the the tent was on the
right near where we were having lunch
and we would just go into the tent
and we would play around and improvise
and out of that
came this idea that he had this liquor
that was in his family
and uh you know that i would unbeknownst
to me
end up i'm trying to get him drunk but i
get drunk instead and he's fine
and uh i realize how drunk i'm getting
and the whole thing of hiding of putting
on the dress
in order to hide the knife under my
clothes we kind of came up
with all of that and we showed it
stephen and
steven loved it and he said okay you're
right let's do it that way
so yeah that was that was great you know
that we got to have a little bit of
uh you know kind of that kind of
creative
energy you know put it into a scene and
and maybe made the film you know a
little more interesting at times
that's incredible you absolutely did uh
and again
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk to me cannot stress enough how
incredible this film is and how big of a
fan i am of you oh thank you
i can't believe four minutes goes by
that quickly i know i know
i have so many other questions but thank
you so much for your time i really
appreciate
it